so let me get this straight
today's topic best friend get in here
get in here get in here
because i'm going to teach you a secret
that men do not want you to know
which is how to make them chase you baby
okay
what i'm about to teach you can make a
man become sprung on you quickly honey
it will set together a scenario where
you hold all the power
you hold all the cards and literally he
is sitting by the phone
waiting on you and willing to do
whatever he has to do
to stay on your radar and get your
attention
you want to be someone who knows her
feminine power is simply using the tools
that i'm giving you
as a way to show him that you know your
value so that he can pursue you in the
way that nature designed because as i
always say
masculine energy is supposed to chase
feminine energy
why
making sure that you stay with me man
there's a lot going on
hey just making sure that you stay with
me on this one
you know what i mean they just making
sure that your dad's older now hey man
listen i can't go anywhere it's almost
like i'm caught in the fishing
hey see-through
what's up i feel like this has nothing
to do with the content and you just
okay and it's weird does that have
nothing to do with the content or what
i will to help you make sure that um
nature is operating in the right way
when you're dealing with a man that you
want darling
because we don't chase men darling we
never ever ever ever ever do that all
right
press pause you want me to press pause
so let me get this straight
oh
okay
no i'm operating under the assumption
that you're gay
we don't chase ben honey well it's like
well you're a man too so if you don't
chase
that means you're not doing what you're
doing so let's go ahead and start with
step number one baby because there's
steps to this thing all right
you have to arouse him now when i say
arouse that doesn't mean that you need
to become sexual with him but what i'm
saying is this
masculine energy is extremely easy to
influence and dare i say it even
manipulate through arousal
when you are around him you need to make
sure that whatever you wear around him
is going to inspire his arousal if you
know he's a guy who likes to look at the
cleveland's
then wear something low-cut if you don't
have a whole lot of cleveland's baby
then put some push-ups up under their
honey they make stuff at the stores for
a reason maybe buy it all right
if you know he's somebody who likes to
look at the cake-ish then you make sure
your cake is out there on display okay
for the push-ups the the under cleavage
stuff that's unknown for me bro
that's enough for me too you know i got
trapped by that once or twice
you know what i mean the deception that
occurred once we entered
it it's even worse when you when you
know you get you got deceived
and i'm not even a titty band like this
is that that's a thing but i think
that's even worse
but that's even worse because we're not
even
on to that and if you got mosquito bites
on them
mosquito bites all right everybody likes
some warm weather it's fine
there's nothing wrong with it but when
you're out there with the fake stuff and
you pretend like you got something you
don't
whether it's ass like it's just it's
unappealing you got pancakes for ass
bring them maple syrup
can i also just appreciate how casually
just saying manipulate men
yes but nobody cares about that
no but no nobody no but we already know
that nobody cares about it
nobody cares about it nobody cares
a man to manipulate a woman is a [ __ ]
boy
the opposite does not exist you don't
you know the people that were expecting
a part two
on the boy video we did way back when
you didn't see it
because it was supposed to be on the
girls because there's no equivalent
it's okay it's okay i'm just saying how
casually people get
casually i'm just saying but anyways
carry on
it's part of that feminine energy i
guess smoking cannabis doesn't have to
hurt
freeze pipes making a unique line of
freezable pipes bubblers bones dab
breaks and more
if you can smoke from it freeze pipe
makes it
the secret is freezable glycerin
chambers that cools
smoke by hundreds of degrees for
smoother and bigger hits
when smoke passes through these frozen
chambers
lift off it's instantly cooled for a
much nicer hit you'll feel
instantly your throat and lungs will
thank you
recyclers are commonly used for dabbing
but freeze pipe builds this
for both insanely smooth and cold
hits go to the freezepipe.com
to get yours today use code aba
that's abba and save 15 off your first
order
you need to be touching on him hey baby
touch him rub on his head when he's
talking you know when he's when you sit
beside him
rub your hand on his inner thigh don't
get too close to his to his goodness
okay
but just rubbing that inner thigh you
want to do little things that
communicate to him
she want me but you don't want to come
on so strong
that he thinks that he can get you
whenever he wants to okay listen i'm
gonna just say this
so far you said nothing of value no well
you said things that we already know
you want to lust after someone sure you
know reach on the inner thigh that's how
i know you're down
but that doesn't mean that i'm going to
chase you
this is this is like basics of teasing
this is not it's not exceptional this is
pretty
dope it's not going to make a man chase
you're going to make a man want to smash
and that's it
all right yeah yeah exactly i got a
that's what i was about that's what i
was about to say
um if you do stuff like that yeah
it doesn't mean that i'm necessarily
gonna want to keep you
it's interesting if you understand what
i'm saying yeah it's interesting
this whole thing is about like getting a
man to chase you yeah
and the first thing he leads with is
innuendo
yes right so he's owning it yes you want
to get him mad
throw your [ __ ] at him and clearly
remember
this is about putting together a power
dynamic that is stacked
in your favor okay so a power dynamic if
it's stacked on the favor of the
feminine energy is okay
with manipulation am i getting this
correctly should i carry on
yes all right my bad i'm putting little
things
in his mind honey i do the absolute most
in the middle of the day i'm gonna send
him a cute little photo while i'm
you know working out in the gym and i'm
all glistening and stuff like that so
i'm a cute little
cute little photo hey babe just thinking
about you
be a [ __ ] boy
everything that you hated being done on
you do on them
this is so basic it's unbelievable if a
girl did this to me i
chuckled it's like this is so basic what
are you doing
are you missing me right now you know
what grown woman you know why you're
chuckling
you know why you're chuckling you're
getting old
that [ __ ] i ain't got that it wouldn't
get it wouldn't get you it wouldn't get
you
oh i got it girl talking about yeah i'm
in the shower i'll call you right back
man i had a girl send me like nudes
thinking that's gonna get me that just
turns me off
i'm doing little things to inspire his
mind to desire me
i do that over weeks and weeks and weeks
and weeks i am
building it up within him now here's the
key he is going to at some point in time
try to make a move he's gonna make a
comment like okay so when can i come
over or dang i really want you he's
going to push for it because remember
masculine energy is the pursuer okay at
some point in time he's going to make it
known
oh i want you here's the key when that
happens don't
give in you cannot give in you will
eventually and i'm going to teach you
about that in a minute okay
but don't give in initially okay when he
says that kind of stuff
what you want to say is and say oh my
god i want you to i woke up this morning
thinking about you and that
but you know i just want to take a
little bit of time because i know you're
special
and i just don't want to rush into
anything okay so is that all right with
you baby you're going to get me
eventually but
can we just wait a little while now the
next step is extremely important and if
you sister super christian or you're
extremely conservative about your
thinking
about intimacy girl cut this video off
because i'm only gonna give you the raw
truth
i'm not gonna give you nothing else okay
when you finally
decide to give him access to your
intimacy if you know what i mean
when you finally decide to embrace him
you need to put it down so good you need
to give it all you got
you hear what i'm saying baby this is
not the time to ration your tricks out
this is not is there any i need to keep
watching
no thank you his first point how to get
him in implied sex
yes step two give him sex
step three make sure the sex is good the
whole thing
is sex basics it's and it's basic
it's basically listen i'm gonna just say
this man if you out there you're on
dating market listen
sex is available whether you date or
whether you pay for it it's available
it's right there okay if your bargaining
chip for keeping a dude
is just what you got between your legs
and and implying that
right as the late great patrice o'neal
said implied [ __ ]
you're never gonna keep a man you're
gonna keep him waiting long enough until
he gets it and then by that time he's
going to cut babies your whole thing is
about something that he said
anywhere it's like a dude luring you in
with money might seem appealing at first
going on those lava strips and all that
stuff but if he has zero character zero
personality
it's like you're not going to want to
build a relationship with unless you're
a money fiend if you're a [ __ ] fiend
that's what you're gonna get
that is what you're gonna get so
sometimes people
like oh i don't i don't know why i don't
keep people it's because you
just base yourself to attract them
something
that there's available everywhere how do
you fish
how do you fish how do you bait a fish
with water now with food [ __ ]
already have
water you can't chuck buckets of water
in the in the in the lake you're not
gonna get no fish use
you gotta have quality bait or bait
whatever they like
basic first graders yeah i haven't seen
the video i just thought you know
it was just i didn't even have to see
anything else it just came back
the advice is absolutely terrible often
and often and i was like you know what
that's cool
let's look at that it's going to be uh
interesting um
fish net yeah no that's it for me
that's all see true fish now you're not
about that
that's a big pass if you combine that
with roller blades [ __ ] you skating to
gayness
no no already a man on roadblade is
already sucks
you don't like rollerblades nah you
don't like the culture you don't know
the culture i
i used to i used to skate i used to i
used to escape when i was a kid
disagree what i disagree you disagree
that i i skitters
no i disagree with that some a guy on
the roller blade is us
it is it's very sus one and the second
thing i'll say
unless you're at a roller park okay
that's a different thing unless you had
a roller park not an atheist
okay i'm just kidding what do you mean
the culture but
but if i just see dudes in the street
generally i'm just like yeah it's a
little
but if you're saying that deep who cares
it's not that it's not important all i
must say is like the advice is terrible
as far as how to get a man there's a lot
of
you know whenever i see videos like this
i always cringe incredibly because
that's just like
you guys have no idea what you're
talking about no and it's basically
basic stuff
most of the people yeah yeah sex dancer
with sex
let me summarize the whole video sex
that's what this video is going to be
about
so anyways let me know what you guys
think in the comments below
what it's just what's that point
sex step number two
postpone sex number three
give sex four
make sure sex is good five
report sex
[Music]
why you wanna be
the one that keeps you